[Music]
hey everybody welcome to predicting
community engagement on reddit using
tensorflow g delt and cloud dataflow
that's the session looking for you are
in the correct place
Who am I my name is Nick Caldwell I am
actually I'll introduce my nonprofit
first to get that other way I'm a board
member of a nonprofit called dev color
whose goal is to advance people of color
into leadership positions and technology
and then maybe perhaps more interesting
to most folks in the room I'm also vp of
engineering here at reddit and yeah
reddit fans in the audience
reddit fans in the audience okay very so
it sounds like a lot of you guys know
what reddit is already for those of you
who don't I'll do like a quick intro
reddit is the front page of the internet
that's how the outside world thinks
about us but inside reddit we think
about ourselves a little bit more in
terms of community so we say we're a
social network where there are tens of
thousands of communities around whatever
passions or interests you might have
where people converse about the things
that are most important to them reddit
for those of you know what reddit is you
may not know some of these statistics
I'm about to throw out you read it is I
would say kind of a big deal fourth
largest site in the United States
according to Alexa sixth largest in the
world 350 million monthly active users
ten point seven million posts per month
2.8 million comments per day 58 million
votes per day and then getting back to
the theme of communities more than 1
million communities on the site and when
we think about communities this year
particularly on 2018
reddit is really trying to transform
itself in the following way we want to
be able to connect people to the best
most interesting communities for them
for those of you in the audience who
have been on reddit for a long time one
question I often ask our users is how
long did it take for you to find your
first community for me that was about
four years we're trying to get that
number down to maybe a few minutes would
be great so reddit is this
network of communities news politics
gaming sports all sorts of different
content we've tried to visualize here
and a question we've been wrestling with
is how do we connect people with the
right communities now later on you're
gonna hear from Sergey and he's going to
talk about some really really advanced
techniques and recommendations but I
thought as a as a cue into that
discussion perhaps we could take a trip
down memory lane and talk about the
history of reddit's data platform if you
will indulge me
so I'll start in 2006 the dark ages
trying to solve this problem of
recommending content to users our first
approach was collaborative filtering the
way Reddit works for those of you have
seen it we have a system of up votes and
down votes so one might naturally think
that if you have the same up voting down
voting pattern as someone else on the
site perhaps you would recommend similar
things to each other and this was state
of the art for 2006 we represented users
as a matrix with posts and what they
voted on
we used cosine similarity distance
re-centered by subtracting the global
global mean and then applied SVD to get
the results now great for 2006 turns out
it just doesn't work we had a couple
problems that we were trying to overcome
data Spartan at sparseness you may not
realize it now but back in 2006 read it
didn't even have communities it was just
one front page listing one big pile of
content so not a lot of interesting
dimensions to look at the median number
of votes per user was pretty much 1 so
very few people actually voting and this
meant that if you have the combination
of everything only showing up on one
page with very few people voting you
really get this mean response behavior
where you're just recommending the same
stuff to everybody and we had no
feedback loop on that except for this is
an example we've taken from 9 years ago
why does the recommended feature suck so
bad are routinely down vote every
American politics story yet my first two
recommended pages are nothing but
politics ok but there was a use case for
this if you can imagine vote cheating so
what is vote cheating
it means explain why you would do this
reddit if you can get your content to
the front page it's actually pretty
valuable several million people are
gonna see that
so Xochitl reddit back in the day create
a bunch of bot accounts have them all up
vote your content and profit and it
turns out that these bots these cheating
accounts also have very very similar
voting patterns you can actually make a
visualization of that this is kind of
clusters of people who have similar
voting behavior on the site and you can
see that in the center there's like the
standard behavior a lot of means mean
response voting behavior but you can see
islands of these kind of unique users
off to the side and these are cheaters
so we did find a way to use that now
from 2008 to 2014 for those of you
understand read its history we'll call
this the dramatic intermission nothing
really happened on reddit from a data
perspective but the site did continue to
grow one great advantage of working at
reddit is the site has just addicted
ictus we call it a weaponize
procrastination and it will grow in and
of itself so between 2008 2014 it's
growing by itself but then the gears
start to come back into motion in 2014
this has read its first real data and
analytics pipeline everything previous
to this was essentially just a lot of
data from logs sitting in Postgres here
we've got Kafka dumping data in s3 being
processed by hive and as you can imagine
for those of you who have dealt with
with hive this is kind of slow it's not
really operational really what this guy
used for was every two months read it
has board meeting and the deck needs to
be created so someone would go kick the
hive jobs and generate the board deck
but it's better than nothing 2015 we
start to get just a little bit more
sophisticated
we added midas for those of you know
that's an open source project that does
enrichment we used it to enrich
geolocation user agent data etc another
year goes by we're starting to get a
little bit more interesting here this is
one hour we can finally do relevance and
feedback we've got two services here the
the blue and yellow one minsky for
those of you folks who are into classic
AI Minsky's named after Marvin Minsky
and this is essentially our first
attempt at allowing the homepage to be
generated dynamically based on user
preference and we'll talk about that a
little bit more later on the second box
is spammer ID and what that is is it
uses hand-tuned rules in conjunction
with feedback from the community in
order to try and dynamically detect spam
and this is really important because
this is the first feedback loop that
takes a data analytics and and drives it
back into the products all right 2017
which effectively brings us to very
close to our present day system we began
forking all of our event data into
bigquery after considering a lot of
different alternatives for those of you
are considering this I highly recommend
it coincidentally that's why they
invited me to the talk here but bigquery
is actually pretty friggin good it's
simpler to manage it's got much faster
query performance you can connect it to
a host of BI tools we use mode looker a
power bi and on top of all that is
pretty freakin cheap which makes our CEO
very happy so we can't say this is a
perfect solution I do have some
complaints about it but I don't really
use lose sleep over thinking about our
data warehouse choice choices anymore
so with that pipeline in place let's
reattempt this problem how do we get
community recommendations in this modern
pipeline well we now have the ability to
get core metrics what our users are
doing essentially in real time this is a
chart of us rolling out the recent
reddit redesign if you go to WWE at comm
you'll get to see what that looks like
this is us rolling out that new system
and data streaming in in real time this
allows us to attempt a few different
approaches our first approach was to use
jacquard distance Sergey I'll get more
academic about this later but jacket
jacquard distance is simply a way to
calculate the similarity between two
sets and this was our first attempt if
you think about each subreddit and the
people within it the people have
subscribed to that sub
as being asset you can then use jacquard
distance to compute the distance between
all of the sub reddits on reddit the
problems here are that we have a lot of
sub reddits about a million sub reddits
this algorithm scales at Oh n squared so
humans did the hard part of essentially
whitelisting the sub reddits we thought
would be most interesting crooning out
the ones that were very very under
subscribed for example second problem we
have a ton of default sub reddits so in
the olden days when you would join
reddit
there was no onboarding flow we would
simply subscribe you to about 20 sub
reddits and this also polluted data but
we used humans to clean that up as well
problem with that is it that still
didn't work really well we still got a
lot of mean response behavior even after
doing that tuning but we had an insight
that was really important instead of
trying to look at user behavior what
people are subscribing to and so forth
why don't we just do something a little
bit different the aha moment we had is
that every subreddit and the comments
and that the texts that are part of the
forum really can be treated as kind of a
bag of words so can we get the sub
reddits simply to describe themselves
and what they talk about so take all the
corpus of commentary on a given subject
smash that into a gigantic document run
doc to Veck on it and now we convert
each subreddit into a 300 dimensional
vector that represents the semantics of
what that subreddit is about and that is
the approach we're using now and what
this gives us is we can now recommend
communities by topic so if you on board
into reddit now you'll be given an
option to choose different topics that
you're interested in health crypto
gaming etc and will automatically
suggest what we think are the most
semantically relevant sub reddits to
that topic so for health you get fitness
bodybuilding for cryptocurrency you get
BTC and eath Greider etc but maybe we
can take that a little a little further
what if you already have found a
community that you like can we recommend
similar communities to the one that
you're already interested in so we use a
very similar technique here using that
that data we can get similarity to
overwatch there's competitive overwatch
there's overwatch University which
teaches you how to play
there's overwatch means which are
essentially little mini videos of people
playing overwatch etc and then you can
do the same thing if you guys are into
machine learning you can check out learn
machine learning math statistics data
science all cover the topic of machine
learning in some slightly different way
but maybe we can take this even further
what if we could dynamically compute the
main listings feed for reddit so when
you go to reddit.com you'll see our
popular listing if you're signed in
you'll see our home feed listing what if
we could make that more personalized and
use signals such as what you look at
what you click on etc when it's old home
feed algorithm if you guys are wondering
how it worked was the same ranking
algorithm for 12 years
a hand-tuned by our most brilliant
engineer who's sitting in the fourth row
and tuned algorithm that we think we
could improve on so we attempted to use
large scale logistic regression using a
time of day subreddit so you're
subscribed to some interests that we
collect during onboarding the device
you're on mobile or desktop and several
other signals 10 terabytes of training
data 50 million features 5 million
parameters and we currently have five
versions of this model in production
trying to choose the best one but we
have some very very promising early
results our early results are we get a
12% time on site increase with just our
initial attempts and this is actually
extremely good explained to you I on the
next slide this is our Alexa rankings
you can see a reddit fourth fourth
largest site on the web and the
important number here is the daily time
on site that column to the far right you
can see reddit is already the most
addictive site on the Internet people
who come to Reddit stay there longer
than any other site and we've managed to
increase that addictiveness even further
now yeah we not letting you go not until
the GDP of the world drops will we be
done
so that's great but what's next now I
want to introduce sorry wait Sergei you
jumped the gun man you got a you got a
butt wait in the wings I'm gonna I'm
cueing you up man now all of these
improvements happened in about the last
year and a half we're extremely excited
about what we've been able to accomplish
now what I'm excited to introduce to you
next is to show off some work that my
colleague Sergei has done and what we
view this partnership with Google has is
what is possible what can happen in the
next year and he's given us a glimpse of
some amazing results so please welcome
Sergei to the stage thanks Nick for the
wonderful introduction so what what I
wanted to talk about you today was
thinking this concept of using machine
learning using big data and data
processing and trying to come up with
some projections of user behavior Nick
talk to you about how by building
several recommendation systems they'll
be able to drive the time on side to
pretty high values so ask myself this
the same question what if we what if we
could project popularity of news
articles on reddit here's an example of
a news article it was written by one of
my colleagues Martin garner some of you
might have heard his session today he
continues writing about tensorflow and
deep learning so this blog post is
pretty Mita because it is talking about
machine learning in terms of law and so
the question asked myself if I look at
this blog post and if I know a couple of
attributes about it can I make
predictions about user behavior
specifically about specifically on
reddit now incidentally this blog post
was shared four times in four different
communities by four different people so
I chose it because it provided me with
some good data on user behavior some
real user actions and it also was
published back in 2017 so now I have
about a year worth of data points that I
can look back
trained my machine learning waddle on so
what are these outcomes that I want to
be able to project I want to deal with
projection predictors and outcomes and
the outcome for me is a user action in
my desired reddit community so the first
prediction or the first outcome would be
what is this subreddit that this blog
post was posted in the other projector
or the other outcome sorry is the person
who decided to share this news article
in the subreddit yet another outcome is
the popularity score that's the most of
the numbers on the left and some of the
postings achieved pretty good scores
almost a hundred if not more others only
got maybe a two or a five and plus Li
one of the one of the possible outcomes
is the number of people who users of
Reddit who come and comment on on the on
the posting and have a conversation
about it
okay so now we understood the outcomes
now we understood how users on reddit
work let's talk about projectors what
are the possible projectors for me to to
build my machine learning model on one
possible projector is the the author of
the blog post so the hunch is the person
who writes a news article or a blog post
probably has a community of readers and
these these people will come to Reddit
and perhaps there's an overlap of the
readers of the author as well as the
users of Reddit and so these folks will
go and share it in the community of
their choice the other projector is the
textual content of the news article
that's the green stuff in the middle
that's the text the freeform text the
topics the news article is about yet
another possible projector would be the
publication time and perhaps the place
the publication domain where this news
article was posted oh so I've got four
outcomes that I'm interested in I've got
four possible predictors before I jump
into talking about machine learning and
tensa floor and deep learning I want to
just quickly cover the business demean
it's always good to kind of stop and
think about user actions and what the
business is about I tend to think of
Reddit as a huge collection of threaded
conversations someone writes a news
article and that person is typically
outside of Reddit thus article gets
posted to I don't know the Google big
data blog or New York Times or cnn.com
or some other publication domain a user
on reddit picks up this article reads it
becomes interested in the content and
decides to share this news article in a
community of his or her choice then
people on reddit come and begin
commenting and we have a conversation on
reddit about this post across all of
these entities and now I'm switching
back into architecture is stuff and
talking about entity relationships so
across all of these entities you always
have the person who initiated this
action and you also have some
differences between entities for example
the news article will have textual
content the blog sorry the reddit post
will have the subreddit and the comments
will also have some textual content oh
great so now we understood the business
let's go ahead and start building our
deep learning data set and so this is
our first challenge and and I'm gonna
talk about how we solve this ultimately
what we're trying to do is to bring two
streams of data the first stream are
reddit posts and comments the other
stream of data are the news posts or the
news articles and so we were lucky that
both of these data streams are actually
available as public datasets in bigquery
the reddit posts and comments are
available in an a bigquery data set that
is maintained by one of our developer
advocates Felipe Hoffa so help tip to
him Thank You Felipe and it draws its
data from a collection of exports from
reddit that are operated by Jason
Baumgartner
thank you Jason for keeping the smoke up
amazing job on the new side we also have
an amazing data set and I also want to
reach out to colorful it ro who is I
kind of who is maintaining this amazing
database of news articles if you if you
want to do read up on it just google the
GDL project the GDL project contains
pretty much every news article I might
be stretching this but it has a very big
collection of news articles from around
the world in lots of languages and it
has a lot of metadata about these news
articles not just the author of the
article or the time when it was
published the URL where it was published
it also has textual content as well as
topics and I'm going to show you how we
used the topics from gdelt
to make predictions so we've got these
two amazing bigquery data sets but I
also want to do some additional
processing it wasn't enough what I
already have in bigquery so I used cloud
dataflow and I'm a product manager of
cloud dataflow and so is useful to be to
have access to unlimited processing
power to crunch through all of this data
so data flow was used for feature
processing and again we stored
everything in bigquery all of our
features and labels are stored in
bigquery great so now I understood how
we build the dataset let's start having
some ideas about possible predictions
when I like to do machine learning I
like to start with a hunch and these
hunches tend to be about kind of user
behavior or how the businesses are as
being on so my hunch was the content of
the news article as well as where it was
published was at the Google's blog post
was it you know maybe a top one site was
it kind of a popular news site so these
two projectors are probably influencing
the outcomes which are who will be
reading this blog this news article and
and the communities they will be sharing
at them well great so out of the four
things on on this slide
three of them are pretty easy to deal
with in machine learning the publication
the main the post submitters and
subreddits they're pretty much
categorical variables you can convert
them easily into numbers and once you
have numbers you can move them into
vectors and you can train your deep
learning models on them but the first
variable here the news the news content
that's much more trickier to deal with
and it is because it's freeform text and
although the right techniques today to
deal with freeform text they're not
perfect so these are the possible
techniques to deal with text encoding so
I'm going to talk about for the next
five minutes about how we use some some
existing encoding techniques and brought
them together with deep learning and
achieve pretty good results Nick talked
about using dr. work and scan a variant
of word to work to make recommendations
for subreddits similarity that's a great
technique
there's also word to work techniques for
encoding text and they have been used
successfully for basic sentiment
analysis and topic extraction but even
before deep learning came on board there
was a huge number of an huge volume of
research done on natural language
processing and I call it pre deep
learning because you know Warwick and
dr. Burton that ended up kind of
overshadowing the the previous research
done in that space so we actually
decided to use some NLP techniques to
encode out text and see how well it
worked and I'm giving you a little bit
of a preview it did work so here's what
we do we take a blog post and I'll just
follow the example of Martin's news
article so we take this news article and
we extract sentences from from text and
we'll we'll use a Google cloud service
the machine learning engine to create
syntax trees and this is an example of
what is called a dependency trees it
basically is a tea of dependencies
between words in a sentence there are
other variants of syntax trees
constituent cities but pretty much we
can you
can have solved the problem by using
what you see here on the screen now once
we have syntax trees we can do a cool
thing called entity recognition I'll
give you an example in my in my sample
sentence deep learning is a popular
approach to building machine learning
models the entity here is deep learning
there's another entity approach and
there is yet another entity models in
addition to entity recognition you can
also do sentiment analysis and nobody's
the sentiment analysis analysis can be
actually done on entity level not just
for the entire sentence but for specific
entities so now we know that deep
learning for example has a positive
score of 0.9 this indicates a positive
sentence so a positive sentiment towards
this mvj now there are other techniques
going beyond kind of simplistic or
simple binary positive negative
classification of sentiment and these
techniques were developed by not by
computer scientists but by psychologists
in the 1980s professor prochik develop a
framework of human emotions and he
showed that all human emotions could be
classified into eight basic ones for
those of you who can't read the small
font I'll just list a few of them for
example one of the basic human emotions
is is joy another one is trust yet
another is fear then we have discussed
the sadness anticipation and then he
also showed that every other human
emotion can be composed as a derivative
of these basic eight for example love
the most human emotion of all is
actually a combination of joy and trust
now you can read up and find some open
source code available on github by
googling github soraka opinions let's
say Java library that classifies text
and parses text according to these
emotions so now we know that we that we
can do much more with text we can divide
it into chunks and these chunks contain
three things triplets
what is the person thinking about an
entity what is the opinion of a person
about an entity in our sample sentence
our entity is deep learning and our
opinion is popular approach now you
might ask yourself who is the person the
person is the person who wrote the
entire article so that's that's how it
works and once we understood this we can
take pretty much every textual document
and convert it into sequences of
entities followed by opinions and
opinions and then another entity in
another opinion and yet another entity
an opinion etc etc etc it's going to be
a long list there's no mistake about
that but it's a structured list it's a
list of just two types which also have
some attributes so it becomes a
structured problem instead of having
unstructured text and so what we know in
in in the deep learning space once you
have structure and sequences we can go
and encode them into vectors and this is
how you solve the the encoding problem
because now you can much much more
nicely encode your text another beauty
of this approach is that it works with
pretty much every topic existing topic
classification system gdelt is a great
example of how you can easily take the
topics that detailed identify identified
and found in text and use it for
encoding text and then using it further
for deep learning because what if you
ask yourself what are topics that is
basically just collections of entities
here's an example of what GDL thinks
about Martin's blogpost there are four
fields here the first one is the URL of
Martin's blog so its core sure it's the
real thing
this is exactly what's contained in the
GDL repository about Martin's blog post
and then there are three additional
fields there's a theme field there's
this the named entities field and
locations field and as you look if you
look at the the themes the things that
GDL found in the news article relate to
education
and jobs if you're AB the article you
would kind of exactly match them and
concur it is about skills and and kind
of learning data flow learning tons of
flow educating yourself
it is about open source and she taught
was also able to find some named
entities the Google cloud platform
developer the machine learning entity as
well as locations Martin's blog contains
references to Belgium so now we have
this collection of things we have themes
we have locations we have names of
people or things and so you throw this
into a bag and once you have a bag you
now know you can do bag of words and
coatings and instead of naming or
calling them bag of words you're calling
them bag bags of things and there are
very standard techniques and deep
learning to take a collection of things
and create a encoding that you can then
further use in machine learning and deep
learning and this is how we bring
traditional techniques for textual
analysis with novel techniques deep
learning we are able to use categorical
variables and this is by the way a chart
of a Karass model and I highly recommend
using Kerris if you use tensorflow so
this is basically a flowchart of how how
entities and variables are dependent to
each other so we take some categorical
variables such as the publication domain
or the submitter of the rabbit past and
we can integrate it together
with textual content through this bag of
things encoding and ultimately we can
make predictions about subreddits so our
last challenge in this exercise was to
deal with multiple outcomes in in
projections as you've seen
as I was explaining earlier Martin's
blog was actually posted in four
different communities by four different
people and we wanted to be able to make
predictions for multiple outcomes I'll
just give you a hand for those of you
who are not dealing with machine
learning day in day out there's a very
good technique and we incorporated it
and embedded it in our cattle Colonel
you can access it later on for
multi-label classification all you have
to do is to tweak your final output
layer and replace the loss function and
change the output activation and do some
fancy encoding of your labels basically
use important coding of your labels
instead of one hot encoding so it works
it can be done all right so we have two
slides away from the demo what I wanted
to show you was kind of concluding now
we have the data set what did we
actually do to develop the model and
here we we were lucky to be able to use
tools such as cargo and collaboratory
coggle is a great site for data
scientists to develop learn develop new
models share their models one thing that
I liked about Cargill was I was able to
use GPUs for training and predictions
and GPUs really make the difference they
make models run 20 20 and faster than
CPUs there is another tool available and
I'll actually be using it in a demo
called collaboratory collaboratory is a
new tool by Google it's freely available
to everyone it's yet another example of
a hosted jupiter notebook by the way
Cargill is also a jupiter notebook and
if you are not yet using jupiter
notebooks you probably should be using
so both tools are kind of versions of
jupiter notebooks but each of them has
has pluses and minuses in collaboratory
skis what I liked the most was that I
was able to directly connect to bigquery
and get my data from bigquery
Kagawa also has a bigquery connection
but it's right now limited to public
datasets
sorry
well great so yep just one additional
thing that I wanted to mention you might
have seen me mentioning a way for us to
do feature pre-processing so what we
used for transforming text and finding
emotional stack in text was a Java
library called Soraka Soraka is great
because it allows you to parse text and
find human emotions and what we also
used was cloud dataflow dataflow was
excellent here because it allowed me to
paralyze the processing of these
millions of reddit posts and news
articles without this parallelization if
I did everything sequential it would
take me years to process these huge data
sets
fortunately the combination of this Java
libraries rocker together with a
distributed processing framework allowed
me to crunch through data very very
quickly so I wanted to show you a demo
and the demo will be about taking
Martin's blogpost and doing some
predictions first off we'll see the
prediction that the model the Train
model does for Martin's blog post
they'll see whether the the one of the
one multiple of the for actual
subreddits a part of the projected
classes and then they're going to play a
production game or we are going to play
a scenario scenario game we're going to
see if by aging one additional topic to
the contents of the blog post would have
changed the possible outcomes and the
other other scenario that we're gonna
try will be what if we took the same
blog post but just published it
somewhere else not on Google's big data
blog but somewhere else
all right and I'm gonna start by showing
you a query in bigquery which returns
the the contents of the GDL dataset as
it relates to Martin's blog I'm just
specifying the URL of my of my blog post
that I'm interested in and I'm gonna run
it
and very quickly bigquery will tell me
what it knows about Martin's blog post
I'm actually going to switch to JSON
format and show you all the fields we've
got this is just to show you that the
contents I'm going to be using for
predictions are pretty much the same as
you've seen on the slide and as they
have it in G Delta so we have our themes
we have our named entities and we have
all locations now the number that you
see here on screen are the offsets of
the occurrences of these teams and
applications and names
we're actually not using them for in the
projection model but there's a way for
using them especially if you wanted to
kind of use sequence encoding and use CN
NS or RN ends we're not going to do it
today but there's a there's some use for
it as well so I'm going to switch to
color collaboratory
and what it shows you is is my jupiter
notebook
they're a bunch of cells here that I
probably don't need so let me start with
the one that actually is important for
the demo so for those of you who use
Jupiter notebooks you're familiar with
the concept of code being in a cell and
then being able to run the cell and get
out output of your code those of you who
don't that's basically what's going to
happen I have some Python code in each
of the cells of this notebook and I'm
gonna run these cells when I explain
what they do and then run them and
you'll see the outputs in this
particular cell what I have here at all
of the instructions to to build my model
and train it on my test data this is the
variable that will hold the model and
the inputs into this model will be two
features I will use the encoded entities
from gdelt
and I will use the publication domain of
of news articles my outputs will be
subreddits that's my prediction that's
my kind of label class before the demo
already RMD the training so I'm gonna
skip the step the next cell and sorry
for all of the comments here I'm just
going to explain what's happening here
in the next cell I have my first
production so I wanted to show you what
the predicted probabilities are of our
model for Martin's blog post without any
modifications so I just simply copied
the and created two variables here which
contain the contents of of the blog post
here are my G del property or entities
and here's the publication domain of
that news article in the next couple of
lines I'm going to run my encoding and
then I'm going to call the most
important function here in the entire
cell which is the prediction and lastly
after doing the prediction I'm going to
print out the probabilities that this
model created
so let me run it alright so here's what
the model anticipates it predicts a
pretty high probability for Martin's
blog was to be shared on the futurology
subreddit as well as on the technology
subreddit and the hacker news subreddit
and if you paid attention hacker news
was actually one of the projected
actually one of the actual subreddits
this news article was was share them if
you scroll down in the list you will
also see the second subreddit which
which does not news article was posted
on the artificial subreddit now you have
to scroll pretty a little kind of a for
a long time until you hit the third
projected class it is in the list of
projected classes it's just one of the
doesn't even fit the top top 100 it does
happen you can you can't always kind of
put human behavior in a mathematical
model but having two out of four
actually three out of four among the top
predicted classes is not bad so here's
my third subreddit which which private
users actually did post this blog post
or and it's a top 111 projection great
so now we have techniques for
multi-label predictions and sometimes
you get lots of health sometimes you get
maybe half of the possible outcomes but
having two out of four is not a bad
thing
so now let's play a plea a prediction
game in my next scenario I want to ask
Google or tensorflow what happened if I
what if I discuss just one additional
topic in my in my model so the the block
was today is about deep learning and
tensorflow what if we discussed just one
additional
here I'm going to take 2,000 entities
from my list my dictionary of entities
and I'm going to go through each of them
and just compose a new text of the new
of the blogpost running through encoding
and pick the top ten predictions and
here are the predictions let's just go
through a couple of them turns out if
you if we or if Martin the author of the
blog brought a little bit about hydro
energy and hydroelectricity he would
have actually a pretty good chance to be
even higher chance of being shared in
the technology subreddit but the top
five subreddits would stay relatively
the same it would still be hacker news
it would be Apple it would be futurology
and the CIA DJ I'm actually not even
sure what the Sabbath is about now let's
look at another prediction what if we
what if Martin brought about Allen masks
it looks like writing about Allen almost
guarantees you good coverage in reddit
the the probability of that new blog
post that has a mentioning of Allen
masks drives your predicted probability
of being shared and futurology pretty
high and for the other classes you know
the the predicted subreddits
stay relatively the same they do vary in
probabilities you might get a bit higher
probability for some of the classes but
if you kind of track what's at the
bottom of this chart you see the same
values and again and again okay so this
gives us something now we have a tool to
to be able to project hypothetical
scenarios where we just add yet
additional topic to discuss in our blog
post and we have immediate outcomes for
possible user behavior on reddit the
other scenario that I wanted to show you
was what if we took this blog post need
no changes to the content
but just published it somewhere else so
this code goes through every publication
the main known to the model and a trans
predictions and again it picks the top
10 predictions based on the sum of
probabilities that's how they are being
ranked okay so let's see the outcomes it
looks like if the published Martin's
blog post on aljazeera.com we would
pretty much be guaranteed a share or a
post on the Al Jazeera subreddit so the
probability is almost 86% as well as in
the village 77 37 years Sabbath for
those of you who don't know al Jazeera
actually has a new spot the three
publishes content that was published on
aljazeera.com so yeah it's kind of an
obvious thing if you publish anything on
aljazeera.com it will get automatically
deposited but for some other publication
domains it's not as obvious for example
if you if you take Scientific American
then you stand a pretty good chance of
being republished to repost it in the
Raytheon subreddit what are the other
subreddits well it's the usual suspects
its technology and futurology but they
have all different probabilities and now
you can kind of decide if you have the
the leverage of publishing your content
in different places now you can make
decisions on okay I want to go with this
publisher or maybe perhaps another
publisher interestingly I've seen kind
of I ran through the test samples before
if you if you ended up getting published
on MIT Technology Review you'd actually
stand a pretty good chance of being
republished in artificial which was one
of the actual subreddits where this blog
blog post was published oh oh great so
we've seen a couple of examples of
how we can use machine learning to to
make predictions for hypothetical
scenarios and for those of you in the
publishing industry or people who write
blog posts I hope this was speaking
convincing methodology and tooling for
kind of making decisions what to write
about and where to publish to summarize
kind of talking about accuracy of our
models we we tried a bunch of things and
the things that did work
I talked to you about today but let me
summarize kind of the path to to success
when we started with just textual
content and these are two models over
here when we only use textual content of
news articles we achieve pretty low
results our accuracy a was in the 55 57
percent range only when we added the
publication domain to the mix when we
have two variables the main and the text
did we ended up pushing and moving
towards the 80% range now we also tried
out a model where we added the submitter
to the mix and made it one of the
predictors you cannot use the last model
for projecting future based on just the
the news article but you can do pretty
amazing normally detection things so for
example if you observe user behavior on
Reddit and it doesn't match this model
then perhaps something interesting is
going on maybe a Baathist is posting is
beginning posting or maybe a user
account was taken over by someone else
we also did some predictions for popular
popularity score in some of the earlier
predictions we've done or models we've
built that try to do regression and kind
of project a number in fifty five
thousand and seven to three as the score
of a news article those didn't really
converge and we didn't really have good
outcomes there but once we
switch to classification and bend our
scores into six distinct classes we'll
be able to achieve pretty good results
in the confusion matrix on I guess
you're right
shows you a nice diagonal diagonal
placement of predictions and through
true levels so I wanted to prop up and
just summarize what we've seen today and
what we talked about today we hope that
next and my story is be able to convince
you that being able to predict user
behavior can have significant impact on
the outcome of your business
reddit was able to drive the time on
site higher you can use for example the
techniques you've seen today to better
place the content in different
publication domains or perhaps choose
different topics you want to write about
these techniques are not unique to
social media you can apply them in
pretty much every industry we've seen
today how text encoding and multi-label
classification and backs of things can
help you even if you are a perhaps you
know a car manufacturer or IOT device
supplier or a cloud provider to build
pretty sophisticated and powerful
machine learning models there's a great
collection of tools here on the slide
bigquery cloud dataflow coggle and
collab tensorflow
obviously I also wanted to give you a
couple of links for all of the code that
we use today for for the predictions and
sampling there's there are kernels on
cargo this code on github I want to give
a shout out to color from GTL project
without his support this this would not
happen the same goes to Jason
Baumgartner from push fi or without his
data again this would not have happened
as well as Felipe Hoffa and lastly if
you want to if you're interested in
machine learning and want to learn more
feel free to check out reddit's
subreddit hopefully this will be the
community that you will decide on within
five minutes instead of taking four
years as as nicob but it's a great
community
of learning resources thank you very
much and we'll be happy to hear to take
your questions after the session
[Applause]
[Music]